hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem subsets 2. we
did solve the first one of this and that
was actually a long time ago and people
have been requesting i solved this one
as well so let's do it today the first
one is actually very similar to this one
the only difference is that in this case
the input array that we're given can
contain some duplicate values now our
job is still the same we want to return
all possible subsets we can from this
input array nums but since we do have
duplicate values it's going to be tricky
for us to not have any duplicate subsets
in our result the good thing is we can
return the solution in any order so
that's good but let's take a look at an
example we have one two two now a subset
of one two two is basically uh some
values from here where the order is
preserved for the most part so you know
we could just take the value one that's
a subset we could take the second value
two
that's a subset as well we could take
the third value by itself which is also
two but here you can see we have a
duplicate right these are both the same
we can't include both of them so you
know we don't include the second one and
by the way even if we don't choose any
of these for example if we just have an
empty list
that is still a valid subset as you can
see in the output over here we could
also take the first one and take the
first two which would give us one two we
could take the first one and then take
the second two but that would be the
exact same that would be one two as well
so we're not going to keep both of them
so you're starting to get the idea of
you know subsets in general and what the
problem here is going to be for us to
not include any duplicates in our
results when we don't include any
duplicates we have six different subsets
that we can create and before we
actually get into the assertion you
might be thinking okay maybe dynamic
programming is something we can do and
that would be possible but i know
immediately by looking at this problem
that we can't do dynamic programming and
the reason is because we're not really
counting subsets or anything like that
we're actually creating the subsets so
even if we found some kind of shortcut
it wouldn't really make this any more
efficient because we still have to
create all of these subsets and how many
possible subsets could we have well to
generate a subset for each value we can
either choose to include this value or
not include that value so for each value
we have two choices now how many values
do we have in our input let's just call
it n so let's say 2 to the power of n is
how many subsets we're going to have now
how long is each subset going to be well
at most it could be of length n so we're
going to take the number of subsets
multiplied by the length of the subset
so this is going to be the overall time
complexity to actually generate all of
these subsets notice how we can figure
this out even though we haven't even
solved the problem yet and this kind of
hints to you how we are going to solve
this problem this is basically a brute
force solution right so we're going to
be using backtracking okay so let's get
into it so let's take a look at an
example and let's just start with the
first subset solution which is actually
pretty trivial for a backtracking
problem remember we want to create every
single possible subset so for each one
of these input values we have a choice
are we going to include this one or are
we not going to include this one so
putting it more simply with a decision
tree you know for the first decision we
have we're at this one right and we know
that because we're going to keep track
of an index a pointer whatever you want
to call it and it's initially going to
start at zero once we make our decision
here then we're going to shift it to the
right and then make our decision over
here and then keep doing that for every
single value in the input but so let's
start with our first decision which is
the one so let's say we do include that
one then we are going to have a array of
one this is our subset so far if we
don't include the one we're going to
have an empty list which is still a
valid subset but we're not done yet we
still have to iterate through the rest
of the array so next we're at the second
decision which is two values so for here
we could either add the two and if we
add the two we'd have one two or we
could not add the two so we're basically
skipping the two which would leave us
having a one same over here we could add
a two which would be just 2 by itself in
an array
or we could skip the 2 which would leave
this being an empty list still ok so we
just finished this value now we're at
the second two and we're going to
continue this kind of naive approach but
now you're gonna see what the problem is
so for here suppose we add this to which
would leave us having one two two if we
don't add the two we stay as a one two
and over here you're gonna see where the
problem is so here we could add a 2
which would give us a 1 2. you see that
we have two subsets that are the exact
same now even though we're not finished
with the array yet uh both of these
paths are clearly going to lead to the
same subsets because they are the exact
same and they the remainder of the array
is going to be the same for both of
these so we're going to end up with
duplicate subsets but the important
question is how did this happen and how
can we prevent this from happening let's
take a look so as we make this decision
tree for example when we're over here
and we're at the two value we know that
all subsets that follow this one like as
we go down the decision tree all subsets
are going to include at least one one
value right and the decision we're
making is okay we're including this two
so if we do include the two then we're
saying all subsets that we create using
this one are going to include at least
one two value so this path is supposed
to be the path with all subsets that
include at least one two and we don't
want duplicates so when we make the
decision on the right side where we skip
this two value we don't include the two
value on this right side so what this
right side should represent is all
possible subsets that don't include at
least a single two basically all subsets
that do not include any two values why
because this left side over here already
includes all subsets that have at least
one two value so if we include any two
values on the right side we're going to
end up with duplicates so what we have
to do is not include any two values on
this right side how can we do that well
basically when we were over here that's
what two we were deciding at right when
we choose to skip this two we should
choose to skip all two so instead of
taking our i pointer and just shifting
it by one to be over here we should
actually shift it by two to be over here
because that's how we know we're not
going to get any more two values but
this input representation might make it
look simple but we're actually not
guaranteed that the input array is going
to be sorted so we have to sort it
ourselves which is going to be n log n
time but that's not a big deal because
we already know that the time complexity
of this solution is going to be about n
times 2 to the power of n so this is
pretty insignificant so now let's
re-draw this decision tree keeping what
i just mentioned in mind and then we
will eliminate all the duplicates okay
so this can actually stay the same
because this is the side where we do
include a 2 but this is the side where
we're skipping all the two values so our
pointer when we're making a decision now
is not actually going to be over here
our pointer is actually going to be over
here at this 3. so are we gonna include
a three or not that's our choice so if
we do include a three we get one three
if we don't include a three we just get
one okay and what about this two well we
chose one two so now the next decision
is going to be are we including the
second two or are we not including the
second two so we can draw that so if we
do include the second two we get a two
two and if we don't include the second
two we just stay as a single two and
lastly on the right side over here are
we actually going to be choosing from
the second two well no because we
already skipped the first two and that
means we're gonna end up skipping the
second two as well so the decision we're
making over here is actually going to be
are we including the three or are we not
including the 3 so that's going to be 3
by itself or just an empty
array and so now you can see that this
is actually
the last value that we were looking at
so we're not going to go any further
down in this case so just to kind of
illustrate that i'm going to put a box
around here this is the base case we're
not going to go any further same over
here this was also the base case because
we were choosing from the three value
here we included it here we did not
include it okay at this point you
probably get the idea so i'm going to
fast forward so over here we either
include the three or we don't include
the three which will leave us with a one
two two three the other one would be
just one two two and the other decision
is just one two two over here if we
include the 3 we get 1 2 3. if we don't
include the 3 we just get a 1 2 and then
let's finish these two as well so this
would be 2 2 3 or just a 2 2 if we don't
include the 3 and then this one is going
to be 2 3 or just 2 by itself so these
are all of our
subsets that are going to be added to
the result output you can see that it's
actually not quite 2 to the power of n 2
to the power of n in this case would be
2 to the power of 4 which is 16. in this
case i think we actually have about 12
of them and the reason is because we're
eliminating duplicates right if we
included the duplicates it would have
been 16 but that's why uh the time
complexity still is the same we can
still say the time complexity is n times
two to the power of n because remember
this is the worst case we don't actually
know if there are gonna be any
duplicates in the input or not if
there's not any duplicates this is gonna
be the upper bound you know if there are
some duplicates the actual time
complexity might be a little bit smaller
than this but i think that's enough for
us with this explanation now let's
actually get into writing the code
luckily it's pretty straightforward okay
so now let's code it up and we're going
to declare our result it's initially
just going to be an empty array this is
what we're going to be adding all our
subsets to and remember before we
actually get into the backtracking
portion we want to make sure that our
input array is in sorted order okay so
now let's write the backtracking portion
we are given uh two main inputs that
we're gonna keep track of one is the
index that we're at in our nums array
and the second is what's the current
subset looking like so far uh we're
gonna have a single base case
and that's when we reach the end of the
input array so basically if i is equal
to the length of the input array nums
that's basically how we know we have
gone through the entire array that means
we can take this subset that we have
built and go ahead and append it to our
result but we want to make a copy of
this subset because this subset is just
going to be an array and we're going to
be using this as we do our backtracking
so what we want to do is actually create
a copy of this subset so that when we
have a future backtracking call that we
don't end up overwriting this subset
because we're taking a reference to this
subset and appending it to this array
what we want to do is create a copy and
we can do that in python like this or
you can use like a built-in copy
function in java or whatever language
you want and after that we just want to
return because we don't want to continue
backtracking when we reach the end of
the array okay that's the base case but
what is the recursive case well remember
we have exactly two decisions to make
one is all subsets that include nums of
i that include the number that we're at
the other case is all subsets that do
not include nums of i so we do not
choose to include nums of i in our
subset let's start with the first
decision what we're going to do is we're
going to include nums of i right so
we're going to take our subset and
append to it this number nums of i and
then simply enough we're going to go
ahead and do our backtracking call by
passing in the next index so we're going
to pass in i plus 1. and we're going to
pass in the subset that we have so far
and you know that's going to take care
of all subsets that include this number
so very easy but before we start
generating all subsets that do not
include that number we should probably
remove from the subset the value that we
just added to it we can do that just by
saying subset pop that'll pop this value
that we just added so now we're going to
generate all subsets that don't include
numbers of eye but this is the slightly
tricky part because remember if there
are duplicates the duplicates will be
right next to each other because
remember we sorted the input array so
what we want to say is
i plus 1 as long as i plus 1 is inbound
so it's less than the length of the
input array and you'll see why we're
doing this and if nums of i
is equal to nums of i plus one so what
am i doing here and why am i doing it
well remember if we have an input array
like one two two and we're at this value
and we're choosing to skip this two then
we should probably skip the second two
as well because we don't want duplicates
right we should skip the second two and
then our index i is gonna be over here
right and we're gonna compare this value
to this value are they equal yes they
are so then we're going to increment our
pointer to be over here now then we're
going to compare this value with the
next value 3. it's not equal so
that's when we're going to stop this
loop right and what this loop is going
to be doing is just going to be
incrementing the i pointer like i kind
of talked about right now but what if we
didn't actually have this 3 value here
in that case our i pointer would be
incremented to be this position and we'd
see that i plus 1 is out of bounds so
then our loop would terminate as well
okay and after the loop does terminate
we still want to run our back tracking
because even if we don't add any values
even if we skipped the entire array you
know this is this case over here is
going to be the case that ends up adding
the empty array to the result so we
definitely don't want to skip calling
backtrack onto this regardless of what
the while loop ends up doing so let's
call our backtracking uh pass in i plus
1 same as we did up above and let's pass
in the current subset
after we have popped the value from it
remember that is actually the entire
code as long as i don't have any bugs
let's run it to make sure that i don't
so first we want to actually call our
backtracking function let's pass in 0 as
the starting index and just pass in an
empty array as the initial subset and
then after that we can just return the
result so now let's run it to make sure
that it works and as you can see on the
left yes it does work and it's pretty
efficient so i really hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it really supports the channel
a lot consider checking out my patreon
if you'd like to further support the
channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching